hundreds of millions of people are
ditching Android Once Upon a Time the
Rivalry between Android and iPhone was
one of the biggest in the world it was
as divisive and alienating as politics
religion and whether you eat defrosting
in an Oreo first the iphoneers were seen
as snobs who worshiped Steve Jobs and
were willing to pay up any price
meanwhile the end writers were seen as
the Geeks Who just didn't quite
understand the Elegance of the iPhone
and for the longest time it seemed like
this battle had been settled the same
way as the PC vs Mac battle the PC was
the choice for the overwhelming majority
well the Mac was the choice for a few
creative types coders and of course
knobs but it's not quite playing out the
same way within the smartphone space in
fact the iPhone has not only been
gaining on Android but it has straight
up overtaken Android in terms of
popularity within the US things haven't
gone that far internationally but the
iPhone is still very much gaining on
Android outside of the us as well in
fact within just the last five years
Android's global market share has fallen
eight percent from 77 down to 69
that might not sound like a big deal but
keep in mind virtually everyone in the
entire world has a smartphone we're
talking about 6.92 billion people so an
eight percent loss in market share
translates to over half a billion people
switching teams another decade of that
and Android will no longer control the
majority and honestly looking past the
numbers it seems like this shift is
already underway back in the day it was
the iPhone users that were seen as The
Outsiders the select minority of Apple
sheep but today it's usually the Android
users that are seen as The Outsiders a
green text bubble is a legitimate reason
to not date someone FaceTime is a
must-have and even Flagship apps like
Instagram and Snapchat are very much
biased towards iPhone as they work way
better on iPhone this is especially true
for younger Generations aka the future
of the smartphone market of whom 79
prefer iPhone hearing that it seems like
the demise of Android is almost
inevitable so what happened to the king
of smartphones
foreign
[Music]
to the Android Community we first have
to take a look back at what gave rise to
the Android community in the first place
and for that we'll have to go all the
way back to October of 2003. this is
when four friends named Andy Rubin Rick
Miner Nick Sears and Chris White would
create Android but it was nothing like
what we know today in fact Android
wasn't even meant for smartphones as
smartphones weren't even a thing Android
was actually trying to create better
software for digital cameras but they
quickly figured out that that was a
rather Niche industry with little money
so out of desperation they would pivot
to the mobile phone industry and got off
to a surprisingly strong start in fact
they would end up having conversations
with Samsung and HTC and these
negotiations would catch the attention
of an up-and-coming startup named Google
Google would seize on this opportunity
and a biota company for a mere 50
million dollars and with Google's
backing Android no longer had to worry
about funding but they still didn't have
a winning product in their hands in fact
Android was initially being developed
for Blackberry like devices with
physical keyboards and no touch screen
functionality it wasn't until the launch
of the iPhone that Google went back to
the drawing board and focused on a touch
screen based experience even then though
they wanted some fundamental functions
to be represented by physical buttons
and that's why all the early Androids
came with the classic 3 buttons at the
bottom this blatant copying made Steve
Jobs Furious as he would vow to destroy
Android but that's a whole other Story
the fact was that while Android had a
rocky start the 2010s would be a rocket
ship as their market share exploded from
some 20 to nearly 70 percent
this explosion can be attributed to
three main factors starting with price
this one is pretty self-explanatory
Androids were in general far cheaper
than iPhones the cheapest Android
started at just 100 to 200 making them
far more accessible than the 600 to 700
iPhones especially in developing
countries but don't let this cheap price
fool you into thinking that Androids
weren't capable in fact antoids often
had way better specs than iPhones for
half the price which brings us into our
second point for Android performance
before Samsung started cheating on
benchmarks and it got banned from
geekbench they used to legitimately be
the king of performance and it's no
wonder why just take a look at the specs
of the iPhone 6 and the Galaxy S6 for
example the Samsung had a 40 larger
battery and nearly two times higher
pixel density three times more RAM at
three and a half times higher resolution
over five times the CPU speed and a
camera with double the megapixels so for
people who made their choice based on
the spec sheet and the price to
Performance Android was the clear way to
go and speaking of choices there were
simply far more choices with Android you
could go with Samsung Google HTC One
plus Oppo xiaomi Huawei and basically
anyone else who wanted in on the
smartphone market from Apple's side on
the other hand there wasn't even phones
with the different screen sizes up until
the iPhone 6. your choices were
basically limited to getting a white
iPhone or a black iPhone and that was
pretty much it also this abundance of
choice or lack thereof extended well
beyond the brand of the phone with
Androids you could take advantage of
widgets swap batteries in a matter of
seconds and add storage like it was
nothing and let's not forget about how
easy it was to jailbreak them
jailbreaking or enabling root access to
an Android phone was literally a matter
of pressing a button with iPhones on the
other hand jailbreaking was a long
intense process as you hoped and prayed
that Jude didn't break your phone but
anyway putting my childhood appears to
the side though when you combine the
price performance and customizability of
Androids it's no wonder why Android
became so popular but with that being
said these factors aren't holding up in
2023 so
what happened
[Music]
looking back I don't think any of
Android's winning factors have
necessarily fallen out of favor peoples
don't want price performance and control
but then why is Android getting
destroyed well I would argue that
Android no longer offers any of these
while Apple has made strides in all of
these let's start with the price for
example everyone loves to talk about how
iPhones have become far more expensive
but have you seen the Android market the
original Samsung Galaxy S1 was launched
for 400 in 2010 alongside the iPhone 4
which launched for 600 dollars
so the Samsung was a solid 33 cheaper
but since then the price of the galaxy
has not only matched the price of the
iPhone or even the pro iPhone it has
literally overtaken the pro Max iPhone
as the Galaxy s20 plus started at twelve
hundred dollars
and it's not just Samsung who has jacked
up their prices Android prices have
exploded to match iPhone prices across
the board as everyone tries to be seen
it as the premium smartphone brand
even the Google pixel 7A which is
supposed to be the budget phone now
starts at 500 now of course you could
argue that the price of the iPhone has
also skyrocketed and that's completely
true but there's one major difference
but jacking up prices Apple wasn't
cannibalizing their own user base in
fact they were just building up the
status and appeal of their phones which
is why a lot of people buy their phones
in the first place
Android on the other hand was
cannibalizing their user base when an
Android User sees that the new Galaxy is
more expensive than the flagship iPhone
most don't say wow Samsung has really
stepped up their quality and Status
instead they go damn if it's more
expensive than the iPhone I might as
well just get an iPhone this trend has
only been exacerbated by Apple becoming
a lot friendlier when it comes to
pricing all we ever hear about Apple is
their Flagship costing more than ever
but here's the deal the flagships aren't
meant for the average person they're
meant for the people who want the best
regardless of price and shaped the Apple
brand image for everyone else Apple has
actually been offering cheaper phones
than ever starting at just 430 dollars
and going up an increments of 100. so as
Androids have become more expensive and
entry-level iPhones have become cheaper
pricing has become a non-factor when
choosing between iPhone and Android
especially when you throw in carrier
deals that largely favor iPhones
but it's not just pricing that Android
has lost out on they've also lost out on
performance
a lot of Androids still have better
batteries and the better processors and
more RAM and all of that stuff but this
no longer translates into real world
performance you see apple has gotten
extremely good at optimizing their
software to work in Synergy with their
Hardware so even though they still often
have more specs on paper they actually
end up having better performance and
their battery life take the Samsung
Galaxy s23 Ultra and the iPhone 14 pro
Max for example on geekbench the s23
ultra comes in at 1877 and 4968 while
the iPhone 14 pro Max comes in at 2516
and 6351 in fact the top 20 scoring
mobile devices all come from Apple but
honestly this is completely irrelevant
because in 2023 performance itself is
irrelevant and that's not to say that
people don't care about performance but
rather that all reputable smartphones
are more than capable
so performance has also become a
non-factor which brings us into the last
Hero factor for Android which was
customizability
to be blunt Android's customizability
has fallen off a cliff they've very much
taken the Apple approach when it comes
to customizing their Hardware you can no
longer switch batteries or upgrade
storage or even plug-in headphones even
getting a charging brick is an anomaly
nowadays these Android phone makers
think that this makes them more premium
and more like apple but really it just
makes them less appealing and as for the
software side of things Android is
indeed still customizable but so is
iPhone after resisting for years Apple
has finally caved and given users
customization options whether that's
dark mode or Widgets or different fonts
or whatever else this has not only
completely eliminated the need to
jailbreak but also the last remaining
Advantage for Android
but honestly while these factors offer a
logical explanation for the downfall of
Android I think there is a bigger more
qualitative explanation at Play
as you can see Android has inarguably
lost much of its distinguishing appeal
over the past decade but I think there's
more to this trend than just objective
reasoning The X Factor that we have yet
to discuss is the rising importance of
smartphones
back in the early 2010s smartphones were
the new tool it helped you reply to
emails and surf the web and chat more
conveniently than ever as such most were
looking for the cheapest and the most
practical way to accomplish these tasks
and this set the context for their
purchasing decision they weren't as
concerned about small bugs or having the
perfect UI or the smartphone experience
or all of these other factors that Apple
focused on these were seen as nice to
have as their luxuries but by no means
necessities and as a result the majority
went with Android but the role of a
smartphone within Society has largely
transformed over the past 10 years
smartphones are no longer just a tool
they are a necessity to engage with the
modern society and economy as such
people are more willing to invest in a
nice smartphone instead of trying to get
the cheapest one on the market
moreover people value the experience
part of it more than ever they enjoy how
seamless eye message and to face time
and now even phone calls are on the
iPhone they appreciate that all of their
favorite apps are natively built for the
iPhone even if they don't know that
that's why the iPhone apps feel better
they love this energy between their
smartphone and all of their other Apple
tech gadgets and most importantly they
value fitting in with their friends and
family
combine this with the fact that Androids
are now just as expensive at lost their
performance lead and come along with
these same shortfalls as apple and
there's really no reason to not switch
the iPhone
and looking forward I think this trend
will only amplify as younger Generations
value these characteristics more than
ever and that's why everyone is ditching
Android Speaking of the modern tech
economy I would also argue that the
modern tech economy is the one that's
destroying the middle class check out
this video to learn more but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
thank you